député et homme d'affaires rustème erov
devrait prochainement devenir ministre
de la Défense ukrainien négociateur
aguerri il avait notamment obtenu un
accord avec la Russie sur l'exportation
de céréales
[Musique]
devrait diriger le ministère
le Parlement ukrainien le connaît très
bien et monsieur humérin n'a pas besoin
de recommandations supplémentaire
j'attends que le Parlement soutienne ce
candidat l'automne sert à se renforcer
gloire à l'Ukraine
au Lexi raisnikov ministre de la Défense
en exercice avait été nommé en novembre
2021 quelques semaines avant le début de
la guerre il sait notamment illustré
dans les négociations avec les
puissances étrangères pour obtenir une
aide militaire mais le ministère de la
Défense a récemment été accusé de passer
des commandes de matériel surfacturés
plaçant Reznikov au cœur de la tourmente
ce changement annoncé par Hélène ski est
aussi perçu comme une tentative de
relancer la contre-offensive ukrainienne
qui a commencé au début de l'été